[Music]
and welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of the careful boys
featuring a careful girl out here today
featuring cat leia everybody hey
cat
and today we're going on the record on
the record off the record on the record
because um you know there's a very large
elephant in the room i guess on the road
everyone knows that you worked at
fighter in the kid if you didn't know
you guys suck but yeah you know she
worked i didn't know that you left
yeah i left recently about a month
almost two months ago i didn't know that
you know how i found out in the in the
jk news comments i'm finding oh really
yeah somebody was like yo since cat is
not with fighter and kid no more she
should just join jk news because they
need more girls on the show and i was
like what
what happened there
she's like we need girls not only are we
hiring we are desperate for guests it's
more that people are leaving so much i
know right that's kidding it's mostly
desperation we find people that we vibe
with for one i think i i want to i want
to keep who don't we vibe with nobody
likes you guys
they don't like us
is there like one person and
particularly they like
the least
who what do you mean oh
shirt pointing
questions
yeah yeah i didn't say anything
like one of these things do not belong
yeah the guy with the biggest dick oh
that's what it is he happens to be
exactly and the wife who's a winner
that's true dude she's killing it
[ __ ] wild i know that's so crazy
green's husband i know right now
congrats on being nicki green's husband
i know right
yeah did you guys hear you guys heard
right wsop she won the world series of
well she didn't win she she final table
which is [ __ ] crazy 700 people yeah
so let's make this video about me
mickey limo it's really not even about
you it's about your wife oh dude
she had my last name so i [ __ ]
claimed that yeah i hear that like
seeing that on the poker site i'm like
that's [ __ ] me right technically
you're a property
yeah and i colonized that [ __ ] every
night
he
on the exact day that all this
controversy was exploding yeah i pretty
interesting
first of all it was so overwhelming
because i put in my month notice before
the episode where i announced that i
left so you didn't see the drama go i
quit pace no i did it a month before who
does a month it's always two weeks only
out here two weeks really i was always
trying to do a month if you like the
place you work at and if you don't then
you quit on the day of the [ __ ] your
manager over yeah yeah did you take a
[ __ ] no two weeks at all that's good
like employee ethics yeah did you take a
[ __ ] on the desk yeah no i could not do
that could i ever heard it oh hard on
the mic yeah that's what you should do
at a podcast studio if you you got beef
weed fart on the mic this is also
hilarious because no one washes the like
microphones
so those are really putting all the dirt
out right now on this you know no one
does though
they just buy new ones or something
right is there any like
yeah they don't the same ones for 20
years everyone's spinning the same mic
yeah that's great
so why did you leave i don't know
anything about this drone
so i moved to
newport beach maybe like it it was in
february it's quite a while ago and i
was doing the commute from newport to
calabasas that's which is yeah so i'm
driving like 140 miles every time i need
to be in the studio
and that's like maybe you messed up
there with the decision making that's
fair i have an idea maybe you could have
moved closer yes critical thinking
skills are not in no excuses i live 300
plus miles away he lives 300 plus miles
away but we're still here at work so
what's your excuse
well actually how often do you film
not very often uh about two days out of
the week but then i'm going to la for
photo shoots and stuff like that too for
only fans so already there yeah i just
wanted to be closer to my family because
i have grandparents in orange county
that's good i'm getting older it's one
of those things where i want us
that's a good wholesome [ __ ] very
good answer now we feel like [ __ ] thanks
that's why geo don't come she's busy
taking care of kids yeah taika and bart
big baby and a small baby but then i
moved and i told him like hey i don't
think i can keep up with this commute so
let's see how it goes and after a month
i was like hey it's a lot i just don't i
also felt like i kind of
not necessarily grew out but the show
didn't need me anymore i was only there
really for current events whereas before
i was doing current events and i was
doing production stuff behind the scenes
i no longer was doing the production
stuff oh just kind of there to sit in
for five minutes of the show and i felt
like i didn't really add anything they
didn't really need me anymore you drove
all the way for five minutes yeah [ __ ]
what are they just fine
every single time so they used to be
that's crazy dude how long did you do
that before uh yeah i was on camera but
for five minutes yeah but for five
minutes some days i did that for about
four or five months with that commute
holy jesus god yeah wow because i was
trying to be a trooper you did you were
a trooper yeah and then i finally was
like you had like a collective 45
minutes of on camera time of four and
five months of commuting yes it's gonna
do the math quick
put the math together in perspective i
don't know here here's what makes it
dumber gas prices went significantly up
when i moved yeah like the six seven
eight dollars you're saying there's a
correlation there's a correlation things
got expensive just want to throw it out
you've been officially on camera here
for five minutes already you already
passed it now i appreciate it like
imagine if i dipped right now okay that
would be so weird it's like a sales
pitch yeah
still a better commute though i i would
say
so i i flew in a hawaii i mean i flew
into la yesterday from vegas right
and i was like oh i kind of miss la
right got my car
and in less than one hour of driving i
said [ __ ] [ __ ] l.a you [ __ ] son of
a [ __ ] and then i'm filling up the gas
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] is this eight dollars
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you know yeah so i get it so like one
hour of traffic myself yeah i would much
rather road trip from vegas
for four hour drive with no traffic
that's actually more enjoyable than one
hour stuck in la traffic speaking of
your commute though yeah okay so now
you're no longer doing that yeah so now
so i what's the drama part i know i see
your part of it this is the possible
time yeah what is that time because he
doesn't know about the drama he doesn't
know about the shop stuff right now okay
so
do you know who she works for
worked with it was a quiz for audi lee
right no bobby lee she just made that
brandon shop brenden shot
it'd be a fighter in the kid podcast
show let's just lie to anthony okay the
christian bale fighter like that one
yeah
so bobby lee and kalila went on
h3h3 and then anthony what's h383 hot
hempboard knights uh
yeah exactly yeah yeah you don't even
know h3h3 podcasts
celebrate southwest like what's a
podcast it doesn't [ __ ] happen that's
why i regret hiring a dancer to the
[ __ ] show what i'm saying dude
what's the food like in el salvador uh
you know i don't know much about the
food but i could talk about the drivers
a little bit longer
you didn't eat a pupusa oh i ate all the
food all right cool anyways back to
anthony
update me on the
drama this is what happens there's a
there's a podcast called the h3h3
podcast okay very popular within the gen
z crowd maybe millennial too but the um
he went on the show bobby and kalyla and
then they said that brandon has been
bullying them
and then all this stuff right so then
that's your boss xbox yes my phone xbox
and they had like texts and all kinds of
tags
took a whole thing yeah kalila was like
he was hitting on me even though he's in
the relationship they're in the
relationship this and that can you
comment on that or no
no comment i actually
i will say that there's a lot going on
and i don't think it's my place to speak
on drama that i'm not a part of it's
just i felt like i was in a
weird predicament because i had put in
my like one month notice and the day i
happened to be leaving was when all of
the drama came to fruition online it
doesn't look good for you yeah yeah i it
looked like i left because of the drama
but i put in a month's notice before any
of that i'm just kidding it doesn't not
look like it's imaging
[ __ ] this drama i can't take it anymore
i quit i heard about the text brandon
i'm leaving
it's not a bad look for you or anything
right it's just i don't condone this
[ __ ] that'd be associated coincidence
but there are people who like to
try to equate things with like oh it has
to be because of this drama well the
math adds up you know you're clearly a
part of the problem
when you're in the public
it just happens
people have to fill in the blanks
they love the stories that's the real
mastermind that's what it is
juiciest thing is what everyone wants to
believe anyway yeah so that what is the
juice of the most boring [ __ ] yeah it's
usually very mundane yeah so let's let's
bring out the real juice thing yeah the
real drink you came on here to tell your
story you only have five minutes of
airtime
cat story and it come out with a book
the expose oh that's
all
behind the scenes of fighter in the kid
that's also hilarious when people are
like oh people are gonna come out and do
like tell-alls when most jobs at
entertainment require you to sign ndas
like did you sign an nda
before every single entertainment job
i've ever worked from the time i like
moved to la even working on an apartment
i had to sign an nda correction what
about this show this show uh you guys
are anti-indiana
you're welcome yeah it's a good business
we want everyone to go out and talk
about it we're trying to start the nda
movie yeah
expose jk it hasn't been catching on but
i
mean
nbas aren't like a bad thing
standard and entertainment i feel like
they give you like credibility for your
show which is why we don't use them here
oh okay
we want the low it also yeah it also
kind of establishes the level of
professionalism in a business which we
don't have
no you wouldn't say we're professional
here dude we tickled our hr lady and she
quit
we were just we kept telling you
huh where did you talk to the armpits
that's a real tickle spot nice and so
innocent right she's like i can't take
it
we got him good man can i get some extra
beats on like what the bullying kind of
entailed i i know they're pretty long
thing i guess but you have to be there
to say that no
all right so i mean there's accusations
of like it's a great way to say no yeah
so like like how um there was
accusations how
bobby they're saying like bobby created
like some kind of reddit group
and they were talking mad [ __ ] on the
fighter in the uh uh uh kid like podcast
form and all that and red and then and
then bobby's like i don't even know how
to [ __ ] use a computer but apparently
that was like
he was like a mastermind he was being
accused of that
um
they threatened to like end his career
they threatened to bully him out of his
career um he didn't feel comfortable
because they do stand up you know stand
up small they they see each other and
then he's like nervous around seeing
them
um also like um i guess kalila
um agreed not to talk with
about this stuff and then um
so did brendan but then she heard that
he did talk about it so she felt like
she can talk about it now and just all
this stuff
um i'm not doing much justice on it
because i think you're doing a good job
actually i'm at least finally getting
some drama details bro didn't like
didn't brendan uh call and then the
other guy and i [ __ ] can't remember
his name that's bobby kellen this is his
life
give me the baton joe i got this i
[ __ ] dropped it
no no no they called bobby they're
yelling at him and like yeah we'll [ __ ]
you up and all this stuff but they're
like like screaming at him and that was
enough to scare bobby and make bobby go
i never want to talk to you again yeah
cuz i heard bobby's uh absolute like he
hates confrontation he's a pacifist like
he can't even go and like like change
the order when they do a wrong order
like he'll just be sitting there like
[ __ ] my coffee's wrong or whatever
they're like go change it they're like
nah
like
a fighter just yelling at the dude and
he's like oh i'm
like so many times yeah multiple stories
so can you comment on all of that any of
that
no unfortunately do you have thoughts
uh i like hypothetically if it was true
then you would feel
yeah
i just feel like this is an unfortunate
situation all around because the my last
day of work was when brian went on
camera and he apologized to bobby try to
be very like is that when he went on his
brian is the other guy you're thinking
of yeah was on fighter and the kid oh uh
the day that i i had my last day of work
and he apologized really sincerely to
bobby because he was like i didn't
realize that like
in me trying to defend brendan i didn't
do my due diligence in trying to figure
out what was actually going on and i
took it out on bobby and so that was my
last day and i feel like it's big of him
to publicly apologize weren't they on
matt tv together yeah they were yeah at
the same time i don't know if they were
during the same time but they were on
the same show yeah because brian was
like earlier seasons i was a huge fan of
brian cowan he's on tv he's so funny
that cast was like my favorite yeah it's
just a shame to see like drama break out
within like a friendship you know
because there no so before the podcast
world bobby uh introduced us to brian at
the
not the laugh factory the other one the
one that they all go to store comedy
store and then um that's like oh that's
the mad tv guy and then i was like cool
and they've been friends like on the
road going to shows together whatever
for a long time so it kind of sucks to
see that it unfolded this way because
they were friends before this whole
podcasting [ __ ] got it so they're
actually they actually had their own
relationship and then like what's
actually going on online now is just
like beef and drama between the friends
but they just made it public because
they have a lot of fans together and
they just want to be
kind of cleared up and then your
situation is because you started the
whole rivalry between them and then you
left at the right time that's the
mastermind it started cat orchestrated
it and at the end she's going to be like
by my only fans you got to walk out a
good plug that's a good player and you
know what you got to walk out of the
building before you blow it up
huge only fans pr stunt like
it's so good she's getting the tiger
belly sims and the fighter and the kid
sims and she's here getting the jk sets
which is very small very very soon
but that's what the ships are on camera
that's my like final plan when this
episode goes out i'm going to reveal
that i was behind all of the reddit
pages
it was you
oh god yeah scooby-doo moment you take
off the mask
i would have gotten away with it too if
it wasn't for you internet
all of our contracts should be on
[ __ ] food wrappers like
or just vietnamese food yeah
is it still it's binding it's still
binding that way because after the show
ryan will throw them all away
that's about how it goes around here
anyway we have no contracts i don't know
where any of the contracts are
you didn't tell me that there are the
body wrappers i throw them away of
course
throw them away we just like throw a fit
we should throw a fit race
that's how much [ __ ] trust we have
for the people that we work with and i'm
just so
amazed at how all of my friends have
been tremendously [ __ ] over in the
past in the workplace
and their businesses and for me i feel
like i got away pretty clean
are you sure
so far
so far
compared to them
squeaky clean out here
yeah jk has nothing like that right
like
joe's the guy whose [ __ ] is bad and he's
like
smells like [ __ ]
i think it's coming from over here
somewhere
hey that's what happens when you have a
senile senior citizen [ __ ] running
the company bro that's right
psychology it's like you're an idiot for
trying to attack me
if you're gonna if you're gonna shake
your pants can you [ __ ] go in the
other room or something
as he turns away there's a brown stain
on his butt
no one wanted to say that it smelled
like [ __ ] because everyone was like it
could be me so everyone was just like
uh so on today's news
you guys smell that so everyone just
assumed they smell like [ __ ]
because i thought it was a trash can it
wasn't quite [ __ ] it was like [ __ ]
mildew it was like wet dog
and you would get whiffs of it and then
like bart was there wait was it bart and
steve there it was me it was me and bart
he's the only one joe's the only one who
could possibly know that it could be
that rug we were all just like
yeah i was like what the [ __ ] is going
on we thought it was the rain or some
[ __ ] outside like the rain guys and at
the end of the day i'm like
oh it's the [ __ ] you right
about all the mold jumps did you break a
wet dog
who brought
[ __ ]
i feel like nda's also go against your
like business model yeah right i think
the more publicity the better
yeah
tell all no risk no reward man
we have to start drama with another
podcast that's what we got to do which
podcast what podcast you guys think you
guys should take off
oh my god we don't have enough drama one
with like 12 viewers we're just just
getting started
we use our [ __ ] ammo on this oh yeah
just dunk on them hard right
maybe maybe about like um maybe like
nating
sir beat with the kids podcast yeah
kendra's podcast is too easy it's right
there it's a gimme it's a lamp 11 12
viewers we start beef with kendra's
podcast what's what's the what's the
basis for hating that's the end of the
video that's all the time we got for
today folks
who [ __ ] does that outro that's all
we got for today
[ __ ] all donut review [ __ ] all right
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
that's it we hate the door bangers are
huge i feel like you need a smaller
community smaller the donuts donut
reviews
[ __ ] train track reviewers [ __ ] you
guys what about the chinese girl that
eats all the dick-shaped clams
oh i love her we should dunk on her
let's leave her alone okay she's cool
it's necessary and that's cool everyone
else
dead hey the guys who do trains in their
garages [ __ ] those guys yeah [ __ ] those
old guys and they even wear the
conductor outfits who are these guys
they're pretty sweet i think
i don't like the ones who do that and
molest children because the oftentimes
is the same right that's what i'm saying
attack them all often times say with
them doing one or the other
yeah he just doesn't like him together
anthony lee supports molestation jk news
house
it's not bad that's what that bit even
you should add to the video
i like that joe wanted to attack a
smaller target and then he attacks his
own business
his own hosts
[Music]